zendaya and tom holland's relationship
was finally confirmed over the summer
after the two were seen making out in
holland's car in the silver lake area of
los angeles the pair first co-starred as
romantic lead spider-man and mj in 2017
spider-man homecoming and it was around
that time that rumors began surfacing
that their real-life relationship was
romantic too in fact in july 2017 a
source told people magazine they've been
super careful to keep it private and out
of the public eye but they've gone on
vacations with each other and try and
spend as much time as possible with one
another in november holland spoke out
about his romance with his co-star for
the first time when he was asked how he
felt about the aforementioned pictures
being leaked he told gq one of the
downsides of our fame is that privacy
isn't really in our control anymore and
the moment that you think is between two
people that love each other very much is
now a moment that is shared with the
entire world still not everything is
rosians rosian zendaya and holland's
relationship take this hilarious moment
from the set of spider-man no way home
for example in a december 10th interview
with siriusxm tom holland was discussing
an onset stunt on the latest spider-man
film and omitted yeah i farted on
unfortunately yeah it's tough the suit's
tight the harness squeezes it squeezes
your intestines asked if he confessed in
the moments then they had chimed in
immediately was like i felt the rattle
sorry about that
that's my bad speaking of revealing
details about their relationship zendaya
recently gushed about holland at a
publicity event for spider-man no way
home as for how she likes to be there
for her boyfriend she told the
associated press i think sometimes you
just have to be a person to vent to
someone to just be there and listen
anything that i learned or have learned
or continued to learn i share with him
and anything he learns he shares with me
while their relationship is now out in
the open tom holland has admitted the
interest in his dating life can be
incredibly frustrating as he told
british gq in april it's very
nerve-wracking it means that if you are
dating someone you have to be really
conscious of their feelings because if
something does happen between the two of
you it's not just happening between the
two of you it's happening in front of
the entire world given their many
adorable moments of pda it seems like
holland has gotten over both his nerves
and the public pressure in fact holland
has zendaya to thank for embracing his
celebrity status and making him a better
man in february he told backstage you
have to behave differently you have a
responsibility to kind of uphold this
idea of being a role model to young kids
and arguably she's the best at that
zendaya on the other hand has said that
holland's professionalism has made a
lasting impression on her speaking
within style in october zendaya gushed
about holland's personality noting that
the actor is naturally charismatic she
said he can make anybody feel
comfortable and have a good laugh and a
good chat zendaya also said that she
appreciates holland for many things one
of which is his ability to adopt the
spider-man character as his own she
explained in an actor way i appreciate
that he really loves being spider-man
it's a lot of pressure you take on the
role of a superhero wherever you go to
the little kid who walks by you are
spider-man i think he handled that so
well and perhaps one way that holland
nails a role over and over again is due
to his perfectionist attitude which was
demonstrated recently during his stunts
on no way home zendaya recalled it was
cool to see how he cares so much about
his work and making it right i watched
him do a fight scene all day which is
exhausting he'd do a move come back to
the monitors watch it and say i can do
that better who doesn't love a
supportive power couple
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]